Good morning everybody. Thanks for joining our
session about integration patterns
for multi-tenant systems.
I'm Alex. I'm a senior solutions architect
at AWS from Germany working with
European software companies
together with my colleague here.
Hello everyone, I'm Dirk. I'm also from Germany.
I work with software companies too. I
work with them on their multi-dimensional
transformation.
On the technical side, my focus is on
everything around integration architecture,
hence also this talk today.
On the business side, I'm very much interested
in innovation culture and
how tech communities can
improve fragmented techs.
So today it's yet another talk about
integration patterns, but this time
with a focus on
multi-tenant scenarios and
SAS solutions.
However, integration architecture
as such
we believe is relevant for
everybody,
and it really doesn't matter
where on your integration journey you
you currently are.
If you operate a
monolithic application
or if there is one component
that gave you a headache and you started
carving it out already
or if you are running and
building
a divide and conquer architectural style
at home maybe with microservices,
you will, you will always
have to integrate with
other systems and it
sometimes. Depends also
if you have
more access to the systems that
you need to integrate with or less
access like the hoodoos here in the orange
circles
can represent your own systems where
you certainly have more access and can
choose different integration scenarios
while the hoodoos in the
blue circle might represent
third party systems that you need to integrate
with. Now
with every journey, and we believe integration
architecture is a journey, you
want to be well
prepared.
If you, for instance, want to go on
this bumpy road,
you want to be well prepared with a high
clearance 4x4 vehicle,
and in the,
in the same sense, you also want to be
prepared for your integration architecture journey.
And
this brings us to two insights. The
first is I only do these
speaking activities because I want to
brag with my nice vacation photos.
And the second insight is
that not only in modern cloud
applications, but particularly also in modern
cloud applications,
integration can't be an afterthought
because it is an integral
part of your
application architecture.
Now
There's many ways to actually design
an integration scenario, and the
first thing you need to make up your mind
is what is the concept or the approach
that you want to use.
This already is quite ambiguous,
and you really need to understand
the implications of each of those
approaches,
but then once you have decided for
a particular integration scenario
which approach to follow,
there's a ton of follow-up
questions and design decisions that
you need to take,
and each of those
can easily fill a one hour
tech talk on its own.
So the
decisive part here is that you should
understand the implications of each of
those design decisions,
and when you look at a
SAS application or a multi-tenant scenario,
you have the additional challenge that
you also need to care about tenant
isolation.
So there's a whole lot of ambiguity
involved here and this is
why it is really, really important
for software architects to be
aware of the patterns and
options at hand and also
the implications that it has.
So I also like to call this
statement the beware of the face healer principle
because there is
really no silver bullet in software architecture.
Every decision you take basically
sucks in a certain way, and
as a software architect,
you should know which one of the
options that are on the table sucks less
than all the other options.
So with that um
we actually wanted to make it a little
bit more tangible and fun today
and uh illustrate everything we're
gonna talk about with
an example customer an example
um technology startup actually.
So Alex, you like unicorns I believe.
Do you want to introduce our example
customer? Absolutely. So there is
a company you would like to introduce.
We use this kind of uh fictional
company across several uh workshops and
formats at AWS. It's called Wild Rides,
and I mean it's a ride sharing service, so
nothing super special except for one thing instead of
cars they have unicorns.
So if you book this rides this will be wild,
right? So I mean this has been
hugely popular because under the hood
though it's quite a crazy business model, it is very
solid technology
and with all the success they have now decided
to move further in their journey
and go into business.
So now they have wild rights for business,
and this is basically a multi-tenant
extension of the current use case. So assume
that you would have
per tenant apps with their own
branding, but you also have special
features for each tenant. You may have a tiered
pricing model and typical aspects
that you would see in a SAS application.
And now the existing infrastructure and architecture
needs to be extended to support this multi-tenant
business. And
this is basically our
sample scenario that we will look into
when we discuss what it means to have a
distributed architecture, but also a multi-tenant
architecture and those complexity
dimensions basically being combined.
So let's look at different aspects of
that, the first being
the interconnection of services within such
an architecture.
So
when we look at wild rides as an offering, it is
coherent from the outside perspective.
It might look a bit monolithic, but it's not.
So first, it's important to understand that wild rights
does not live in isolation. It lives
in a context with tenants and their
systems,
which are the applications like a mobile
app that we are deploying and providing to them.
But the tenants as businesses also have
their own, let's say finance systems
or a federated identity management
service that needs to be integrated with
the wild rights core system.
But Wi Rights doesn't want to do everything themselves
as a smart, scalable startup,
they have decided there are things we don't want to do
ourselves. Obviously nobody starts building a payment
service provider,
but even email is something that you don't need to build
yourself, right? So this is a commodity
you put it
somewhere else and
focus on your core business.
So this is basically the external integrations
that this company has,
but if you look into the wide rights architecture,
you will see that it's also distributed, so
it would have, let's say something like microservices,
whatever you would
understand that to be.
These services talk to each other,
but we need to make it in a way that is scalable
and resilient.
So how is the best way to build this?
Right, one prominent example
for the interconnectivity is
that SARS applications apparently
expose APIs. This is, and
it is probably nothing new for you,
the way how SARS is consumed. So
you have tenants that consume
APIs from your offering.
Let's illustrate this um with a use
case. So the use case is that an
end user
that belongs to a tenant books a ride
with the app.
We have our Wild rights
application and it exposes the
right bookings API.
On the client side, we have one of our
tenant's users, and they apparently
want to submit the right details.
Now the natural approach that
most of us would probably try
first is to use the synchronous
request response pattern here.
Because most of us are used to this, this
is the way how we
were using software,
programming languages all of our lives
that we send
synchronous requests to functions
or procedures, and this is also the
way how most of us consume websites.
So this would look like this. The client
sends out a post request to wild rights.
It takes a while to process.
And this while might be
also
too much for a good user experience
because only after all the
processing is done under the hood,
the client would receive the
response
with the details that the booking has been
successfully, hopefully successfully
processed. So
why can this be not the best user
experience because we have a lot of
stuff to do under the hood and certainly
Alex showed it before there's an external
payment service provider involved. We also
want to capture the money upfront for
the ride. That might take a while.
So it's not the best user
experience. And why is that so? Because we have
that tight coupling at runtime between
the client on one hand
and the back end on the
other hand,
and this is apparently an inherent
characteristic of the synchronous request
response model.
By the way, this is also called
a conversation pattern because it spawns
a conversation
between two parties.
But what would be a better way to
improve the user experience here?
Well, we can
progress and look at asynchronous
request response,
and in this case, the downstream
request looks the same.
And luckily HTTP supports
this asynchronous behavior by
responding with 202 accepted now and
a representation of the task
that we have
created under the hood on the backhand
side. The actual
processing with white rights will still
take the same amount of time,
but the user doesn't have to
watch that spinning hourglass all
the time
and can continue with
whatever they want to do next.
Now, in the best case,
you are also a nice
citizen and provide your
customers with a representation
of that status and a link for
the customer to retrieve a status
update. So that's the customer while they
are. Waiting for the processing
can have a look hey,
how far are we already?
So in this case
they can use the link that has been
provided with the response and
send a get request downstream to retrieve
a status update and if they do it very
quickly
there will still be the task and status
representation hopefully with a link to retrieve
another update.
And
maybe 2 minutes later or so when also
the very slow external payment service
provider has done its job, we will
retrieve a representation of the
actual successful
ride booking,
and that's the convenience functionality
that I would recommend to offer your customers.
However,
you obviously don't want to force
them to use this and also
provide a push notification once
you are done with that.
So that's the asynchronous
request
response pattern
that improves the user experience
by reducing the runtime coupling
between components.
Now, looking at APIs, Alex,
what is there that we need to
look at in terms of multi-tenant architecture?
That's a good question because again APIs,
many people think would be something like RESS which is more
synchronous,
but in this kind of distributed architecture
it needs to be scalable across several patterns.
We need to introduce things that deal with the
complexity, as I mentioned, of SARS and of
distributed architecture. So we are going to introduce
two more patterns that we can use,
and when I say patterns, it's actually more concepts
that you would have to translate into patterns implementations.
The first one deals with multi-tenancy quite obviously
that's a SARS identity. The other one being
back pressure,
which means that if you have a
bit of your infrastructure that is at the capacity,
you would not accept new input like messages,
but instead fail gracefully and let
the producer of the message know that
you are out.
So how does it look in practice? Let's say again
we have this uh multi-tenant system
and we need to um.
Transport the information about the
identity of that tenant
across the interactions with tenant systems
like mobile apps or finance systems.
One way
of many
is the usage of jot
tokens.
So I think most people of you have heard of jot
tokens, maybe using them in their own architectures,
but let's recap quickly what that is. The idea of a
jot token is a,
well, in this case you see it, it's a, a piece
of Jad Jason
that you would use to transport
information across the bits of your architecture.
The important thing here is when you submit that
it comes with a signature of that message.
And that signature
guarantees the integrity of the message.
So you can, for instance, send a job to
to a client.
They can read it,
but they can also ideally verify the signature
and know that the message is
true. So the veracity of the message is guaranteed
here. And this is a very common
pattern even outside of SARS, but they can use it
in SARS context in combination with
distributed architecture
to transport information about the tenant.
So if you have a mobile app.
Then you can inject information like
the SARS uh tenant ID
or maybe their name, but even
things like the tier of your um
tenant
and this will allow consuming systems to
work with that information without going to the
sort of truth to retrieve it again
because again you can validate diversity
of that. You can even do more
than just conveying this more simple
meta information.
You can have even technical
information here. So when we talk about back pressure and
meaning that we decouple the
producing system in terms of
capacity and quota from our consuming
system,
we could convey that information to the producing
system already so that it doesn't have to
run into a failure, but can itself
manage that before running into that.
So we could say that for example a
customer in the basic tier would have a certain
quota, they have an amount of requests they can
do per minute, per month, or whatever,
and you can then say a premium
customer or a higher tier customer
would have a higher quota.
Obviously you can also say that here's an enterprise
customer does not have any limitations at all,
and they would be able to
submit as many messages as they want.
So this is the way to kind of
extend the
functionality of jot tokens in
order to convey the information
to your producing systems without having
them run into failures,
and this will be very useful as we go further
through this talk so keep that in mind
as a very useful mechanism
to transport this.
So let's have a closer look at what happens inside
the white rights application.
Because right now we have been looking at the
external systems,
but internally,
as Doug already said, there are things happening,
so we expect that the
app sends us a request, we would return with the
HTP 202 that is established
and we said that we will not process everything
immediately. So what happens instead if it's not
a full cycle?
The way Wild Rights choose to implement
this is through a message bus as the first
point of decoupling the
booking service that takes in the
booking
from the Downstream systems,
and the message bus allows us to
spread out
the booking information into other
services that need to work with that. So for
example, here we have a planning service that
does resource allocation.
We have a payment service that will be working with
an external payment service provider.
And we have some loyalty services that
would allow us to, you know, give customers
some goodies if they're, you know,
use more and more of our service.
So the downstream service is external
again and we would assume that it expects a synchronous
HTP request. We cannot do much more
here. We will come back to that later,
but within our own architecture we can
use
decoupling mechanisms like queues.
In order to decouple again within
our architecture services
from their downstream consumers.
And these message cues is something that's not
new but it's still very, very powerful mechanism,
and especially in multi-tenant architectures we can
apply specific patterns
to use those cues in a way to
take a load of producers and consumers.
We can even use cues
as we evolve our architecture. So let's say
this loyalty service turned out to be a
bit sluggish and slow,
and really we don't need to process loyalty
information in real time. So this is not very relevant to
the booking. So we say after a time
we introduce a message queue and refactor the
message, sorry, the customer loyalty service
to consume those messages afterwards.
So this is an evolution of your architecture that
would be more and more decoupled along these queuing
patterns.
Now the queues being our main
way to create resiliency
and scale is something worth
looking deeper into. And so if we
look into what the queues do here.
Oh. Pushing the wrong button.
We see that basically we have a producing
system with multiple tenants.
We have a consumer and we will not look closer
into that, so it's just a blue box at this point,
but we have now a queue that contains
the messages of several
producers.
And
That is a very good mechanism, so in
stable, happy scenario there will be no problem.
Messages will be consumed,
processed as we go,
but it may happen that one of those tenants
will start a large bag of messages.
So
that can happen under two circumstances. One
would be that specifically that tenant
or the users from that tenant would create a lot of
booking rights, like let's say
some tech company has a large event and
would invite everybody to use their right services,
or it could be that the consumer has a tenant
specific problem like a misconfiguration
or some, you know,
contractual thing not working right,
and that could lead to a scenario
where that particular tenant.
Kind of clogs the cue for
you. So that would
lead to that tenant
using up the resource of clogging it and causing
a starvation of the
consumption of messages from other systems
and this is what in a multi-tenant system we
call a noisy neighbor.
So in this scenario, tenant one would
be a noisy neighbor
that impedes the business
functionality for other tenants,
and this is the question can we do something about
it, Dirk? Do you have an idea?
I have several ideas. Nice. Let's start
with a general consideration.
A general consideration that you can
always
apply in this situation and in
other situations is load shedding
and back pressure. We've already heard about
back pressure on API level,
but you can also use it
further down the line, for instance, directly
on your producers.
But let's go one step back and
have another look at the characteristics
of cues.
So the nice thing,
why you would want to use cues everywhere
in the end, I like them as you can
imagine. is
that they solve a lot of problems for
you. First of all, they can buffer messages,
and in that respect they further
reduce the temporal coupling between
upstream and downstream systems.
When you use APIs,
you cannot send a request downstream
when the downstream system is
not actively listening because it
is in a struggle maybe, but with queues,
the queue in between will buffer the messages,
and with that it comes with a
with a peak load flattening
functionality that is really super
handy, so you can protect your consumers
downstream.
Also, because every message that
goes from a queue to a consumer goes
to exactly one
consumer, you can easily scale out
on the consumer side if
the number of messages in your queue
becomes very high.
But then,
You probably only want to scale out
so much
because you have a cost cap on the
number of compute
that you want to add on the consumer
side. So if
you constantly receive more messages
than you can actually consume,
your queue will start
to fill up.
This is actually not a problem or a disadvantage
of cues. You would have that problem
anyway, but cues makes this
actually visible, so you can
then do something about it.
So that's a very, a very positive
characteristic here.
So
I said load shedding and back pressure, load
shedding with queues sounds quite brutal.
You can just throw away messages
that have reached a certain age.
You wouldn't want to do this blindly,
but let's imagine in our ride booking scenario
you might have an ETA
or an SLA rather that says,
OK, dear customer,
we guarantee within 5 minutes your booking is
processed. If a message
related to that is in the queue for more than 10
minutes already,
you can probably throw it away
because the customer is not interested
anymore. But probably you don't
want to apply this blindly. An important
thing to mention here is also this is
rather a business decision and
not a technical decision, so the person
who owns this use case, this
feature,
needs to decide, when can we
consider a message stale and
should probably throw it away.
Now back pressure is on the other
hand a signal that you can send to
your producers to slow down.
In the ideal case, you
send it all the way up to the end user client
and keep the end user client
from sending more requests, but
also the business requirements might
not allow it.
Alex has shared already how you can apply
the back pressure on API level
if you want to apply it also on the
producer level.
You need to have access to the producers
and you have to add some codes that
reacts to signals on it.
Now, on the other hand,
what are you doing with this
information as a producer while still
more requests are coming in and you get a
signal from downstream, you should slow
down. That alone is a
daylong, weeklong business discussion
probably,
and it can fill several
talks. Parts of it are being
covered in the other
patterns that we're now looking at.
And you can combine load shedding and back
pressure with all the other patterns that
we are now looking at.
Alex, I have decided I will
make it very simple for myself
and just create a single tenant
queue for each of my tenants.
With that, I only have to add some
engineering when a new tenant is
on boarding. I need to set up the dedicated
infrastructure for it.
Not only the queue,
probably also producers and
consumers,
and then while I'm running my
application, I only need to multiply
everything I'm doing with the number of tenants.
Does that sound great?
I'm not sure. When I think about it
a little bit more,
maybe it's not the best idea.
Also from a cost perspective,
you want to have an insight into
the queue. You want to make sure that messages
are being consumed from the queue.
If you have tenants that are not
super busy but rather idle, you still
have to look into the queue to pull off
the messages. So you constantly have to operate
on the compute,
so that's quite wasteful.
And
this waste is being multiplied
with the number of tenants that you have, with
the scale that you have, so
maybe not the best idea.
Maybe we shouldn't go into extremes.
We have a broad spectrum maybe, and
we looked so far at the one end where we
had one multi-tenant queue for all of the tenants
and at the other end of the spectrum
where we had
multiple STQs for each of
our tenants.
Alex, is there something in between? Maybe?
Let's see. It's a good question.
Because again I mean you said it at the
beginning, in the end it's a trade off between
several patterns that we can apply and we can show
some that we've seen in reality
which are a bit more elaborate but would maybe fit in
the middle of this spectrum.
So let's look at some of them. One would be
a pattern or an approach called cell shing.
The idea here is that rather than having a
multi-tenant queue for everybody or a single tenant
queue for each individual tenant,
you would share queues between several
tenants.
And the idea here is basically that you reduce the
overhead of the infrastructure deployment.
And at the same time still have the reduction
of the blast radius. So for instance,
if two tenants would share a queue
and tenant 1 would become
a noisy neighbor,
then the only affected other tenant would
be tenant 2.
Still bad enough for them, but if you
think about a, let's say operational scenario
where you need to investigate and address
this and reach out to customers,
then you would have much less headache if you just
had to talk to two tenants than everybody.
So this is a valid approach that we've seen in practice.
Again, it's a trade-off between
the simplicity of a shared queue
versus the complexity overhead here
and the reduction of blast radius,
but we can take this even one step further.
Another pattern that we've seen in practice is
called shovel sharing.
It looks a bit similar like the one we've seen before. We
again have tenants distributing into queues,
but here it's a bit of the other way around. So
rather than sharing
one queue between 2 or 3
or 5 tenants or however you see
fitting. Each tenant would
write into multiple queues, so in this
case you would see that one tenant writes
into two queues.
What's important to understand here is that you need to monitor
queues because the idea here is that
you would monitor the size of the queue.
You can do this with Cloudwa for
instance, and if one queue fills
up, the tenant would be writing into
the other queue that they have at their disposal.
You see here a mapping of I
think 8 queues to 8 tenants, but of
course you could have a higher number of tenants writing
into fewer queues.
That really depends on the load
patterns that you have in the architecture.
Now what happens if one tenant becomes noisy?
Let's say tenant 1 starts producing
a lot of messages and fills up both of
the cues they're allocated to.
The good thing in this scenario is that 10
and 2.
would still have another cue they can write
into and would not be affected
from that
noisy neighbor as such.
The same is true for tenant 8 who, as you
see in this
would also be writing into a shared queue with tenant
1, but again they have another one they can write
into, so they also would not be
affected unless they themselves or other tenants
in the shared queues would become noisy neighbors.
But the likelihood of that happening is
considerably small. I think we calculated it it's
for a set of 100 tenants sharing
them, it's in the area of 0.02%
of likelihood happening.
So this is a very resilient pattern.
It comes with an overhead.
Of having to monitor the queues of course of setting
them up and maintaining them
as you on board new tenants, you will have to
review if the setup is still enough so there is
some maintenance and
engineering overhead involved, but it can help you
to not run into the overhead of having
all the consumers, all the queues for each
tenant. Now
this, the, the previous two patterns and
actually also the multi-tenant single tenant queues
assume that all tenants are treated equally.
Which is nice,
but in business we may have different
pricing models, we may have tiers,
and in that scenario we could say actually we
combine this in a different way. So rather than
having this kind of cell charding and shuffle charing
approaches,
we would say simply.
For premium customers, we would have
a dedicated queue and they would not be
affected by noisy neighbors,
whereas for
basic tier customers you would have
those shared infrastructure assuming also that they
don't have that many messages to produce
and everybody could be happy.
So this is also a valid approach again has
some engineering overhead, but it would scale
with the customers that also
pay for those services.
So
this is quite static approach, but it
helps you to build this out. It would be cool
if we could do this a bit more dynamically, right?
Indeed,
let me look at it. Yes, please.
All right.
So we can actually build on
this approach and look
at a dynamic version of this.
Imagine during runtime, the
producers
can have an insight into the
fact that in this case 10 and 2
became a noisy neighbor through monitoring,
for instance.
Then the producers can autonomously
decide
to create a producer
controlled, in this case overflow queue.
Apparently the consumers also need to know
about it. That means there needs to be
a signal from the producer side
down to the consumer side
to indicate, hey, there is now
this additional queue
for this current noisy neighbor
situation. Please also consume
from there.
This opens up
a lot of questions
again on the consumer side.
When we when we receive the signal, hey, we
should also now consume from that overflow
queue, what does that mean?
Should I do it in a round robin way with
the main cube? Should I prefer
one over the other? Who decides
that? So there's several
decisions that we need to take.
Another thing that I personally dislike
a little bit with this approach is
that we now have again
the direct connectivity between
producers and consumers while
we actually wanted to get
rid of it in the first place
by the introduction of cues.
And then
another question on the consumer side actually
is, would we reuse
the current consumer fleet or would we actually
create some overflow consumers?
Well, from a SAS um pricing and
packaging perspective,
you can
make up your mind also in such a
situation, would I um charge
that particular tenant an extra
cost
for that because we have some effort.
You can maybe do the same from
the other way around, a consumer controlled
overflow queue,
because there are situations where
the noisy neighbor situation isn't
detected really from the producer
side by a lot of requests additionally
coming in,
but maybe from the consumer side. If you
run into a situation where the actual
message processing takes more
time than expected
or you receive an increased error rate
from those consumer processing parts.
In that case, the consumers
can actually do the similar thing
and also trigger that
an overflow queue is created for
this noisy neighbor, and now
the consumers need to send
a signal to the producers,
hey, please use this queue now also
for all subsequent messages
for tenant 2.
Well
then again,
how do you balance on the consumer side with
the two queues that you now have and maybe there's
a third noisy neighbor and you have
an overflow queue for that one
too. There are tough
decisions required here, so
when would I use my
consumer capacity for the main queue
and when from the overflow queue so that
I make sure
I don't leave anyone back
in starvation.
Also, there's quite some engineering
required here to do that dynamically
create all that infrastructure and
also make sure when the noisy neighbor
situation is scaling down
again that we don't throw away
a queue while there are still messages in
it. It can be quite hard to
build this all and to
decide on all those questions how to use my
capacity.
Alex, what do you think? Wouldn't it be nice
if there was a cloud service that could
just implement this for us
and and leave it
in a way that it still looks like
one queue? Yes, it would be awesome. Not
so much engineering effort, isn't that what the cloud is all about?
Yes, that's right.
So luckily this summer Amazon SQS
Fair Ques has been launched,
which is a feature that does exactly
this for you. And from the standpoint
of your producers and your consumers,
you still work only on one
queue under the hood. There are
the overflow queues that
do all the
required engineering to solve
this noisy neighbor problem for
you. Looking
at SQS, I mean, if
you employ cues in your architecture,
um, you shift a lot of operational responsibility
to that messaging system, right?
So you want to make sure that this is
one that is highly scalable, available,
and reliable.
And in terms of scalability,
I can mention a fun fact from Prime
Day 2025.
At peak, Amazon SQS handled
million messages
per second, per second, exactly.
So it is,
it is for sure scalable.
All right,
now.
We can continue with the next chapter.
We solved the noisy neighbor problem on cues.
Yeah, so keep that in mind again, combine the
complexity of multi-tenant systems with
the complexity of distributed architectures,
and again cues are not the only way you
can uh use different mechanisms. We have seen
message buses. You will probably know about
streaming systems.
They help with decoupling and they underlie
similar mechanisms.
So, uh, again it could be a dedicated
talk to talk about those as well, but this is a very
powerful tool.
And we can actually employ this also when we talk to
external systems. So we have seen before
in our example architecture
that we call several external services
and if you have built these types of
applications, you probably know that dealing with payment
service providers can be especially challenging.
So in the next scenario, let's isolate
some building blocks from the architecture and
look a bit closer how the flow works here and how
we can enhance that
with the tooling that we have established.
So assume that we have 3 contexts.
One is the tenant context where we have a user app
calling our booking flow,
and of course at the end of this whole
round trip we need to inform the finance system
of a transaction being made.
The whole thing will go through our booking flow, and we'll
see in a second what we can do here,
but the system we need to interact with is the
payment processor of our PSP.
As we have said, the PSP
expects a synchronous call.
We cannot do much about that. It might be that they
are able to send notifications, so maybe they
also do this 2001, 202
thing, um, but expect
that we cannot have them call from the queue.
But we can use queues ourselves within
our own context. We just need to proxy
the access to the queues.
So in this flow we would have a
request queue for the basically outbound
messages,
but because the payment service provider
doesn't even know what SQS is or our
dedicated cloud services,
we would have a little proxy service that is
just there to pull from our queue and
make a synchronous call.
This may seem a bit redundant, but the obvious
benefit here is that we don't have to implement
this within the booking flow and potential
breaks or
uh congestions would not affect the cure,
uh, booking flow,
but we would have a little, you know, imagine a
lambda that just pulls from the queue, does
the request,
and ideally would not have to wait
for it the whole processing time. So this is the,
uh, my wish scenario
that it could just notify me as soon as processing
is done. But if the payment
processor would say I will not only answer
synchronously,
then of course you might be using something like a container
and you would have of course the wait time
for the few seconds that the PSP needs
to respond to you and then of course instead of going
through the API gateway as in this example
you would just have the response
put in by the calling
service by your PSP proxy
and so this is a pattern where you would introduce a queue
on the way out to a different provider.
And basically
creating a proxy to their system
even though you would have to make a synchronous call
again. So
this is an example that assumes
that these flows always work.
It may be, uh, you know,
delays. There may be back
pressure coming from that other system,
but let's assume now that there is an outage
of the PSP, maybe even again a tenant
specific one.
So in that scenario we would not be able to
submit messages to the payment processor.
The way we could address this is by the
pattern of a dead letter queue. So the
idea is that you have another
queue
where messages that could not be processed
would land into
and would, for example, if it's about payments, could
go into a reconciliation service that once
daily just processes the
failed messages and tries to capture the payments.
In a multi-tenant system you could combine
this with the logic where you would say
not every tenant gets to benefit from that.
So let's say a user from a base tier
customer tries to make a booking, but
the payment doesn't go through for whatever reason, cannot
pay for the ride.
You might say I'm failing this, so it's
right now not possible, which is unfortunate for the user
experience, but it's the base tier, right, so you're
not having any large benefits from that, but
you could say premium customer has a bit of
store credit
and they would land in this reconciliation
service and you would say, OK, for now
you don't have to pay. I tried to capture it later
because you are our esteemed premium customer,
right, so you could have a tenant-based logic of
handling these kind of reconciliations.
Now I'm assuming we have captured the payment
and the last thing we need to do is get back
to the
original.
Or to the tenant's finance system,
how can we do that? So we have fulfilled the whole
flow, as you know, we have originally
established the authentication with the customer,
uh, but in order to find out the callback
to the finance system, we would have to make another database,
uh, call to get to the source of truth,
which is fine we could do that, but actually we
can go back to our little joint token
here and inject
the callback to our finance
system here as well.
What we do here effectively is rather than
convey that information to another system
is convey it to ourselves,
so we have a kind of a closed loop and a joint token
and just let us have this information
ourselves without having to retrieve it again
from the database.
And actually we can then use that to
access the webhook and make that call.
There's just one little problem here.
These jaw tokens are signed, and
we can be sure of the integrity of that
token. But if that
callback,
which is effectively an API call, contains
any kinds of tokens,
then this is unencrypted,
right? So we need to be very careful
if we put confidential information there.
Of course everything goes over HTPS and
whatnot, but there may be side
channel attacks. There may be
security flaws in the system of the
user.
There may be other ways to intercept that, so we need to be
careful what you do here.
And so it's important to emphasize if you
employ this jolt mechanism to
transform, transfer information
across your architecture
either within your own architecture or
with external
partners,
you need to not only
sign this message but ideally also encrypt it
and the good news is that there's a. Standard around
J, so most people know Jort,
but uh I'd like to show here that there's
a whole standard around that
that also has, as you see in the third line
encryption standard. So RFC
7516 allows you
to have encrypted J tokens, and if you employ
that mechanism to convey confidential
information and need secrecy
on top of veracity,
then you need to um.
Encrypted as well. The good thing is there are several
libraries that do that for you, so with a few lines
of code
you can build that out in your architecture.
Now this has been
several use cases where we talk about pipe,
sorry about cues and about draw tokens
to convey information,
but it might be that now we need to externalize
the state.
How would that work?
Let's see.
Um, to introduce that, uh, let's
have a look at another
complex integration pattern. It's
also a conversation pattern. It's
called the scatter gather pattern, one
of my favorite ones,
and, uh, it addresses the question
how can I distribute
a task to several parties
and afterwards
collect the result to find um
the best response or maybe aggregate those
responses.
How would that look like? We have that requester.
And here, since the same
request should go
to multiple downstream systems, the
recommendation would be to use a
publish subscribe messaging channel
here, for instance, Amazon SNS
topics, thinking again about shifting
the operational responsibility
to a third party system, and
Amazon SNS is capable
of that.
Now this message,
or those messages rather
reach all our responders. They can
work on their individual response
and send those responses
back to a response queue where
later than an aggregator in
the context of the requester
can do some aggregation and
there's a final processor for the
final processing.
So
again um this is about finding
the best of all responses
or finding
or creating um the accumulation
of all responses
that are coming in.
There's one thing, however, or actually
two things to help our patterns,
namely that we need to make sure
that also the responders
know where to send their response and
then also the aggregator and processor
systems afterwards can assign
those responses to a previous request,
which is. The correlation ID
and return address pattern that's
meta information that we inject
into the messages.
Here Message A contains an address
of that response queue and
a correlation ID that the
responders are asked to
also forward back into
their responses.
What is a practical use case for this actually?
So coming back to Wild Rides,
let's assume Wild Rides customers
are quite special.
They don't always want to just get
the next unicorn from around the corner.
Sometimes they also want to
ask for a quote
and ask the unicorns, hey, what is your
special offer that you have?
For instance, we're in Las Vegas this week.
Maybe there are unicorns that offer free
drinks during the ride or so,
and maybe a customer is interested
in that.
How would that look like
implementing the scatter gather pattern with a
concrete use case.
So again, we have the Wild Rides customers.
They use their app
and then it reaches the right booking service.
What happens here? So we have an intake
processor and now comes the state,
the external state into play.
Um, we, um, persist
the incoming request
and then we share it in
the right in the RFQ share topic
and only then we return to
the end user client
that we have accepted this
request. Under the hood, what
happens next? We have the unicorn
management service and then unicorn
management resources in there that
reflect each unicorn that is
in a certain vicinity, and they
receive a push notification, Hey, there's an
RFQ running. Are you interested to
participate?
They can make up their minds
about their individual um response,
send it back to the RFQ
response queue and where the response
aggregator stuffs it into
the RFQ store.
And then again we have the usual scenario
for end users how to track
the current status.
They can refresh
the current task status,
get an update
again with a link to refresh another time,
and eventually they will see
that the result is
ready with status done and can
retrieve it from the system.
And again this is a convenience functionality
that you want to add but of course,
you want to send a push notification
too. Now we
externalize the state in this
RFQ store.
So what do we need to take into account here,
Alex?
So first, I'm learning a lot about unicorns today. That's
really amazing what they can do,
very technical animals apparently.
So the important thing from an architectural perspective
is that we need to store it somewhere in a
highly scalable manner, right?
And for that, as you maybe have guessed by
the icon you see in the middle here, we are using a
key value database, in this case Dynamo DB.
And we will have a look at how we can do this
in a
single table design, which is the preferred
pattern to work with Dynamo DB databases,
but also in a multi-tenant way.
So first let's look at
an approach where you would have each tenant
with their own database, so it's not really multi-tenant
at this point,
but really just to simply recap
how you would do single table design with
Dynamo DB.
If you haven't worked with DynamoDB yet or
designed these kind of single table approaches, there
are a few concepts that you need to understand. So
unlike in a
relation database, we would normalize the
data and have several tables for each entity,
you would put all the data
objects into one table
and have them identified by a
combination of a partition key
and a sort key.
So these are the identifiers for your entries
and then of course you would have the
attributes or the key value pairs
in this entity or
entry. So this is
basically when we talk about unicorns
submitting their offer,
we could have the RFQ itself as
one row, so we store here
as an ID for the request for a quote
and then each unicorn would submit it.
Technically speaking, what we are doing here in this
design is we put the ID of the
RFQ into a partition key.
And we put the type of
the message or the entry
into the sort key and if it is
an offer we separate it through a
hash symbol
and then we add the idea of unicorn
submitting that offer
and this allows us to use
the query patterns that we need for the scatter
uh um gather scatter gather
approach sorry
uh in order to work. So these are typically two
requests we need to get a single RFQ in
order to represent that in a user context
and as soon as offers come in.
We may need to get all
um offers that belong to one RFQ
and you see here
that if this is for a single RFQ we
just call by the identity of the
partition key and the sort key
and you see that we can use the
begins with syntax that we start
to request
to get all offers for one RFQ.
So this is very nice, it works quite nicely. This would
be the
kind of a similar thing like a
per tenant queue.
But again it doesn't scale very well when we need
to onboard customers and create new
tables every time.
So ideally we can apply this single table
design in multi-tenant way
and actually that's not super difficult because we
don't need to change much. We just need to
add the tenant ID
to the partition key here
and this would work quite nicely so problem
solved forever.
I don't know. There's one problem with that. So
it would technically work you see here that the
access patterns are not very different from the queries
we had before.
One thing
that is still important in a multi-tenant
environment is tenant isolation for
security reasons or for others.
So what we
lose here as a trade-off with this approach
is the data isolation.
So when a tenant
would go rogue
and it would maybe breach the security
of the querying system, it could
access data from other tenants.
So we could, and again this is an architectural
decision we have to make.
Also built this in a slightly different way, and
this would be we put the tenant ID as
the sole partition key and would
have all other information about the RFQ
ID, about the unicorns and their offers
into the sort key.
This would work almost there as well.
And you could now use identity
access management as you see on the right hand side of
the table in order to have a role
level isolation of these entries,
and now you could say each tenant only
gets to see their data based on the assumption
that the request would be made with this
identity.
There's however, another problem here,
especially when you use different types of
key value stores, and this is called hot partitions.
A hot partition um is
when, as you see here we have the uh partition
key. If a lot of entries
go into one partition key and create
because in the end it's stored physically somewhere,
um there are certain limitations. So first
there is a maximum partition size.
That is 10 gigabytes if I'm not
mistaken. And
it used to be
that if you have a lot of queries into
one partition key
that you would exceed your request
resources. The good thing is if you ever heard of
hot partitions, it's not that much of an
issue in Dynamo DB anymore
because Dynamo DB has a mechanism called
split for heat,
so it would automatically repartition
based on the frequency and volume of
requests coming in.
There may still be edge cases if you scale
very rapidly in new entries that the scaling
of the splitting mechanism takes a while to
do the partitioning.
So depending on your multi tenancy use case,
you may run into
aspects of hot partitions
and then you may need to go to the
design we've seen in previous slide
which would create much smaller partitions
so. This again leads
us to the realization that no
architecture is without trade-offs.
We showed you how to introduce
patterns
that are exchangeable at
several parts of architecture,
but in the end, each of these introductions
needs to be a conscious decision. You need to weigh
the trade-offs, the pros and cons,
ideally create an architecture decision record
so afterwards you know what has been done there,
and then you will choose the least painful
option. So we hoped that we were
able to give you some options when you design
those rather complex systems, the multi-tenant
distributed way.
And uh would like to uh thank you
so far,
but before that we would like to ask you
if you like this talk please rate it in the app that's very
important for us
and we have collected several more resources
for this session. So if you would like to learn more
about how to build SARS on AWS
with AWS services or maybe with uh
open source tools, there's a lot of talks
that we had at this reinvent at previous
sessions.
Thank you very much.
Thanks a lot.